it has been a few weeks now since you
came out as
queer how have you been feeling now that
this is out to the world
the overwhelming amount of you know
response to it
was absolutely crazy but you know after
having a few weeks to let it settle in
and i feel
so free so so real so authentic so just
just me for the first time in life
would you say the pandemic and spending
a lot of time
with yourself that we've all been forced
to do
kind of got your mind thinking and
almost pushed you in a way to come out
absolutely 100 this pandemic has been
the most transformational time for me in
my entire
life and uh you know it was only just
before
it all started that i kind of fully came
to terms with who i was and
and fully just was like you know this is
who i am i'm not going to fight it
anymore i'm not afraid of it
i started dating you know my first
boyfriend for the first time at the very
beginning of all of this
so it's like all of that together just
sort of
created uh this whirlwind of you know
it's time it's time to just put it up to
the world it's time to just speak my
truth say who i am
we're still in a time when it's not
accepted the fact that i had to go
through what i went through growing up
with all the fear and you know the
the repression and stuff and um living
in a conservative religious area i'm
like no like i need to
be a person who kind of stands up for it
as an example i guess and then hopefully
that helps in some way
you used to actually watch conversion
therapy videos
online to try to like pray the queerness
away it was like a it's been a journey
i'll tell you that
you know i think growing up and not
really having like examples or not being
exposed
to that culture and also being in a very
strict religious setting
i would read articles online and try to
like watch like videos of how people
would like convert and stuff and so i
i just i didn't want to be that because
it was so wrong i was taught it was so
wrong
um from a young age and then you know as
a teenager
as you start to develop and you know
start to have these feelings and and you
know start to kind of realize more and
more what sexuality is i was like oh no
like this is like a
real thing i fought it like through my
teen years until finally i just accepted
it in my late teens and i was like no
like this is a part of me this is
like this is this is me it's just been a
very complex complicated journey but i'm
just so glad to finally be
finally accepting of who i am and not
not think there's anything wrong with it
well we have a mutual friend by the name
of priyanka
you know priyanka shared her support for
you online your fans were so supportive
what did it mean to kind of get that
feedback from your fan base
and people like canada's drag race
winner it's funny because i i knew
her before she ever did drag and so
um it's kind of like this full circle
moment where i just came back around and
i got to tell her like i remember
watching you on
drag race and saying you know just be
gay just be gay
and that was just a huge inspiration for
me to come out too because i was like no
there's no point in hiding it anymore
i was not expecting the post to to do
what it did like there's hundreds and
hundreds of comments of people
just having all that all that support
from people who are also in the
community too that's that's another
thing i don't i
didn't know too many people from within
the community but to
realize all the support within the
community as well is just incredible so
it's more than i could have ever asked
for your music has really taken off
i think i saw that in my head had over
10 million streams worldwide that is
incredible
now that you have this new sense of
freedom is that going to give you a
chance to
feel um not that your music wasn't 100
authentic before but is it going to take
your music to a
new place would you say a hundred
percent
and um you know my music yeah like
before it was it was i was i was playing
it safe in a way it was authentic and it
was stories that i created and obviously
was very proud of but now i feel like
going forward i'm actually
like now i can just go into sessions and
write exactly what i feel and
i think i was trying to discover who i
was at that time too so it wasn't fully
you know authentic to who i am now
to me there's now no boundaries before i
was afraid of being you know too
feminine or too like flamboyant or
something or two to whatever it was
whatever the label was
now i can just create whatever i want to
and that just opens up the sky and the
universe
and everything and i'm just excited
about it so i'm just kind of starting
into that creative path now which is
really exciting
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click
subscribe or watch these videos